hi this is press talker in this video
I'll teach you how you can do the times
table from 6 through 10 on your fingers
you can follow along with me place your
two hands in front of you and imagine
numbering your fingers six through ten
going from your thumb to your pinky
finger let's do the problem of seven
times eight we'll rotate our left hand
so we have one finger being seven and
we'll rotate our right hand to line up
the number eight now we'll count the
numbers of fingers that are below the
two fingers which are touching we have
two fingers on the left hand and three
fingers on the right hand which is a
total of five fingers
this becomes the tens digit of our
answer the fingers that are above the
touching fingers are three on the left
hand and two on the right hand we
multiply these three times two is six
and that gets us our answer of fifty-six
you could use this procedure
anytime you're multiplying two numbers
between six and ten let's do another
example of six times nine we'll rotate
our left hand so that we are having the
number six and we're going to rotate our
right hand to line up the number nine we
now count the number of fingers that are
below the fingers that are touching
including the fingers that are touching
so we have one finger on the left hand
and four on the right hand which becomes
five fingers and this is fifty because
the fingers that are below the fingers
that are touching are always counted as
tens now we have four fingers above the
fingers that are touching and one finger
on the right hand we multiply these and
we have four we add those two numbers
fifty and four to get our answer of 50
for this procedure always works for the
number six through ten
let's do a final example of six times
then we'll rotate our left hand so we
have the thumb as the finger six we
rotate our right hand to the index
finger of seven now we count the number
of fingers that are below the two
fingers which are touching including
those two fingers we have one on the
left hand and two on the right hand
which makes for three or thirty now we
count the fingers which are above the
fingers which are touching on the left
hand we have four and on the right hand
we have three we multiply these four
times three is twelve so we add 30 and
12 to get 42
and in fact 6 times 7 is 42 so it's a
pretty neat trick thanks for watching
please subscribe to my channel I make
videos on math and game theory you can
get my books about math there's a link
in the video description you can catch
me on my blog mind your decisions which
you can follow on Facebook Google+ and
patreon you can also catch me at
pressure Locker on a bunch of social
media sites and thanks for watching